finalement avec siouxsie on n'a jamais
été voir jack nicholson dans five easy
pieces le jour qu'on attendait la séance
snack du drugstore
il ya suzy qui regarde un mec et qui dit
jésus soit et même jésus quel mal je
vais bien je garde le type et joue un
type insignifiant je sais pas si oui les
genres de niro dans taxi driver alors je
me tourne bien siouxsie calmement vous
souvenez de la scène avec paul newman
dans left handed gun d'arthur penn what
you you really want était confuse m
illzach what you want you to aéré moi
j'ai été co font ici et souzy a eu un
geste qu'elle a piqué à elizabeth taylor
hachad a alors je me tourne vers de niro
calmement ont marre on nous ment y est
même mère
bronson fait souvent ça à ce moment là
de niro se lève et je m'aperçois que
c'est un faux maigre ce qui arrive
souvent l'examen frère quand il se lève
il change de catégorie et là c'était
plus du tout de niro mais jean athmane
dans french collection de john
frankenheimer pittman le bit
je vous passe les chars russes rockot
please stop ou lienemann est prise drop
in drop it hymne des coques de terre et
pendant qu'ils postillonner je me disais
je connais cette scène mais impossible
de le souvenir du titre du film et c'est
seulement quand il a dit je vais démolir
tout de suite je me suis souvenu que
c'était la version française de ram
people un film de francis ford coppola
un film de la warner en si bonne marque
produite soeur bat patton ronald colby
script writer francis ford coppola
lui-même et dans ce film c'était jones
kahn qui disaient non pas je vais te
démolir mais a une gueule à brioni avec
une musique géniale avec jésus mais ces
fusils qui souvent va voir les films
deux fois
ok ok ok ok ok beaucoup de gens qui vous
diront qu la bbfc lemaitre revient vers
moi en roulant john wayne jean on se
prendrait il va pas me faire le coup
classique du mauvais feuilleton american
séries v vous savez la fameuse pochette
non pas faire ça quand même
eh ben le garde pas du tout c'est ce
qu'il a fait il a pris le pouls de
moutarde et lentement il ment à tartiner
lager plein d'humour il m'a fait le coup
des marx brothers dans itunes casablanca
la classe mais vraiment la grande classe
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'ai
laissé suzy partir avec lui
by sony mais ça plaît pas saisie
c'est et jeanine